meine damen und herren dankeschön
dankeschön dankeschön das ist wirklich
sehr nett dankeschön sieg entfernt eine
damals 13 er ist wieder zurück meine
damen und herren der beste fortnight
spieler ich mein mann mein letztes video
hieß ja sogar bester fordert spieler
also das ist bestätigt dass ich das bin
ich spiele ja heute auf jeden fall mal
wieder solo eine runde fortnight solo
weil ich habe keine freunde mit denen
ich ein team machen kann ich werd mal
wieder genau hierhin fliegen wo ich am
ende der letzten folge auch waren
nämlich hier vorne genau hier unten ist
nämlich nix aber übrigens freuen ich
habe neun scannen die kiste die letztes
mal hier war es hier gerade auf jeden
fall nicht mehr da vorne rechts liegt
aber eine waffe ich glaube dies
gewöhnlich also die wie zumindest
relativ grün aus ja die das ist
definitiv grün war allerdings natürlich
nur ungewöhnliche waffe freunde ich habe
ja ahnung von vor neid ich schaue erst
mal hier vorne kurz nach ein paar waffen
die ich mir irgendwie noch gönnen kann
weil ich meinen die hier
er hat die geht aber dies hat jetzt auch
nicht so krass
[Musik]
meine damen und herren dankeschön für
den applaus wieder an der stelle war mal
wieder eine mega lange runde hier von
mir da will ich euch meine neuen skins
zeigen und es geht einfach nicht weil
ich direkt getötet werden aber das mache
ich mir jetzt ich habe tatsächlich geld
investiert dieses spiel meine damen und
herren und hat mir diesen skin gekauft
ich weiß nicht wie ich mich selbst von
vorne betrachten kann aber es ist auf
jeden fall der t rex ging mit dem
rucksack der kostet glaube ich 2000 von
diesen münzen
vielleicht werde ich ja mit diesem
screen jetzt ein besserer spieler immer
wieder schön rausspringen meine damen
und herren mein ziel diesmal ist dieses
dorf da hinten nice freunde von haben
wir direkt eine hand kann ohne gefunden
da ist sogar ein bisschen was drauf
hiervon des direkten typ aber ich weiß
ich hab deine waffe hat oder nicht und
so muss der mensch ist er abgehauen
bewusst der freunde hier drin befindet
sich auf jeden fall im spieler ich weiß
noch nicht wo mein gott was das denn so
fängt der spaß steht an zu tanzen alter
hey was geht denn ja mein gott ich habe
zehn hält gerade ich weiß nicht ob sich
das von alleine auf links oder ob ich
jetzt irgendwie im verband nehmen muss
weil ich habe keinen verband was ich
meinen dass man so sehen wir hier auf
jeden fall erstmal sicher der hat wohl
irgendwie so ein teil aktiviert dass es
so aussah als würde ich tanzen und ihn
deswegen nicht abschießen können also
ich weiß nicht was da jetzt gerade
passiert ist aber ich brauche auf jeden
fall ein scheiß verbands um ehrlich zu
sein habe ich sogar überhaupt keine
ahnung ob es überhaupt verband heißt was
ich gerade braucht oder ob ich einfach
nur so ein health drink oder ob ich in
mountain julia weiss ich trinken muss
toll munition also hier oben befindet
sich tatsächlich mehr oder weniger
eigentlich gar nichts das heißt ich muss
halt echt gucken wie ich da irgendwie
mit meinem herz jetzt mal aus komme hier
vorne im dorf ist auf jeden fall
eigentlich kein spieler mehr das heißt
irgendwo hier muss doch ein verdammter
verband sein hier ist eine granate drin
und noch ein bisschen munition
dann haben wir hier vorne hier ist die
kiste und haben wir darum gehen
net kit also wenn ich jetzt hier das
medi kit nehme und so mal drücke dann
verbinde ich mich eben kurz hier unten
läuft gerade eine zeit ab ich weiß halt
real talk nicht ob mir das irgendwas
bringt ja aber ich habe wieder 100 hertz
okay das ist schon mal mehr sehr sehr
gut das heißt jetzt kann ich auch hier
vorne noch die waffe mal eben kurz
mitnehmen jetzt wird gekämpft ein paar
sekunden später
wir sind außerhalb des sturms an alle
unter euch die fortnight nicht so
wirklich kennen beziehungsweise das
spiel so richtig können es hätte in
meinen augen abschauen
ich bin der beste spieler
[Musik]
ihr seht oben rechts man die karte
eingeblendet und zwar bin ich jetzt in
dem kreis drin und zwar ist jetzt das
auge des sturms das ist dieser bereich
hier und diese himmel da vorne zieht
sich quasi zusammen so wie bei hunger
games wo das dann kleiner wird am ende
damit sich die leute halt treffen und
nicht immer die ganze zeit voneinander
weg laufen bei der größe der map auf
jeden fall muss ich jetzt gerade mal so
langsam hinlaufen einmal schauen ob wir
vor genau was drin ist
hier ist nichts und deswegen glaube ich
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen weiter
die mit ich habe nur angst dass hier
hinten irgendwo sniper sind ich meinen
wer sich an die letzte folge erinnern
kann weiß dass meine angst da auch nicht
unberechtigt ist denn irgendwie wand im
weg ist oder so dann nutze ich nicht die
tür oder suchen den weg oder wir sind
jetzt gerade an diesen lagerhallen
angekommen wo ich auch letztens schon
mal war
wir haben hier auf jeden fall noch
irgendwas um liegen hier ist ein trank
warten kann ich mal eben kurz trinken
jetzt habe ich so einen schutz quasi die
kiste da wurde schon geöffnet aber das
sind auch nur gewöhnliche sachen das
heißt wir waren auf jeden fall schon ein
paar spieler hier liegt noch irgend
schnitt drin
ich kann mal kurz nach schauen hier ist
eine armbrust
ich bin gespannt wann wir hier die
ersten gegner treffen weil wir
eigentlich gar nicht so weit außerhalb
sind also dass die depots auch schon auf
jeden fall keine ahnung was ich gerade
aber ich habe keine ahnung von diesem
spiel hier vorne haben wir auch noch ein
bisschen eine armbrust rumliegen aber da
mir unendlich munition hier vorne liegt
noch ein jagdgewehr und der taktische
schrotflinte nehme ich jetzt mal nicht
mit weil ich hab mir eigentlich ganz
vernünftige sachen glaube ich aber dass
jetzt auf jeden fall mein neuer skin
dieser tracks gehen ich bin auf jeden
fall sehr zufrieden damit ich finde gar
nicht ganz 1 1 sieht so ein bisschen
kinder das hat sich gelohnt luca war so
ein bisschen nach kindergeburtstag aus
aber finde ich eigentlich ganz frisch
hier das ist das ist das ist ein toller
raum
ich habe halt wirklich noch keine ahnung
wo jetzt irgendwie gegner sein könnten
wo er so schoder uns da hinten ist
das auge des sturms zugleich auf jeden
fall schon wieder kleiner
da hinten sehen wir den gegner ich weiß
nicht ob ich dem um mein gott mein hat
mich gesehen bin ich ein volltrottel
alltag ich nehme jetzt mal so eine
granate und schmeiße da vorne hin auf
seine sachen
keine ahnung ob da jetzt irgendwie was
mit passiert hier vorne ich weiß nich
hat er sich jetzt ein haus gebaut
oh mein gott
ich bin komplett dummen dieses spiel das
stimmt aber ich meine auch gott hier
meine damen und herren ich nehme das
ganze spiel natürlich auch nicht so
ernst natürlich okay ich gefilden immer
aber jetzt würde ich sagen machen weil
hier mal ein bisschen mehr action nicht
so die ganze zeit hier immer außen rum
und hier mal schauen was da passiert wie
gehen wir direkt hier in die großstadt
hier vorne mehr in dem gebäude schauen
ob sich hier vielleicht im keller was
befindet würde ich jetzt mal sagen dass
hier eher was ist als oben hier und
haben wir nur verbände hier befindet
sich gar nichts drin doch das ist doch
eine truhe hier vorne haben wir eine
truhe meine damen und herren
da haben wir auch wieder 0 sachen aber
doch doch doch wir haben auf jeden fall
schon eine waffe hier allerdings nur
noch ungewöhnlicher also jetzt nichts
blaues lee landes oder goldenes hier
oben haben wir noch eine grüne waffe
noch ein paar sachen was habe ich oben
noch hier oben haben
noch ist das ein kleiner schild trank
dann trinke ich den auf jeden fall schon
mal eben
mal wieder eine super runde hier gewesen
ich mein okay wenn man besser gewesen
wäre hätte daraus eventuell ein
vernünftiger kampf entstehen können den
ich eventuell auch gewonnen hätte aber
ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau
anschauen was wir hier vorne erstmal
haben ich bin jetzt hier gerade unseren
gebäude rein gegangen
hier war kohl munition für welche waffe
cooler kampf mal wieder habe ich schwöre
euch freunde jetzt springe ich als
allererste raus also die ganze zeit
schön leertaste drücken jetzt direkt mit
wen nach unten so damit wir die ersten
sind die wirklich da unten wie konnte er
vor mir raus springen also hier auf dem
dach liegt auf jeden fall eine blaue
waffe das heißt ich werde jetzt einfach
mal hier direkt landen dann haben wir
hier direkt die blaue waffe und jetzt
schauen wir mal wo eventuell noch gegner
landen könnten damit wir die quasi
direkt wieso kriegt er kein schaden ich
habe jetzt auch eine falle gefunden das
heißt sie setzt sich jetzt einfach mal
hier vorne hin falls er nach unten
laufen möchte und jetzt gehen wir mal in
die stadt bevor wir aber in die stadt
gehen freunde ich habe hier noch ein
sturmgewehr gefunden goldenes das ist
das erste mal dass ich was goldenes habe
glaube ich wir befinden uns auf jeden
fall ein bisschen außerhalb des sturm
august das heißt wir müssen jetzt auf
jeden fall ihr seht ihr oben rechts den
fall wo wir jetzt in laufen müssen ich
bin aber definitiv gespannt ob wir
eventuell diese runde etwas reißen
können weil ich meine freunde goldene
waffe ein paar sekunden später alter von
wo keine ahnung wer mich davon wo
abgeschossen hat aber wir haben auf
jeden fall nur noch anderthalb minuten
zeit um irgendwie etwas weiter in die
mitte zu kommen so dass uns der sturm
nicht tötet weil damit haben wir auch
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
[Musik]
ich meine hp ist gerade nur circa bei
der hälfte das heißt ich stelle mich
jetzt mal kurz hinter dem baum und
wickeln wir mal kurzem etikett um ich
habe natürlich eine mauer bauen können
aber das sehe ich so aus als könnte ich
diese spiele ich mein ja natürlich gibt
es leute in amerika irgendwie habe ich
mitbekommen dass ein kanal von 0
abonnenten auf zwei millionen abonnenten
innerhalb von einem monat hochgegangen
ist nur wegen fordern und auch 80
millionen views in einem monat gemacht
hat das sind natürlich leute die sich
kratzt damit auskennen und mega gut sind
und auch viel zeit
mega cool meine aufnahme ist gerade
einfach gestoppt und die kamera bleibt
halt danach noch drei minuten an so dass
ich das dann erst realisiere ich habe
auf jeden fall gerade den typen getötet
wo kann ich das hier irgendwie zeigen
ich mein ich kann euch ja eben den kampf
noch mal kurz einblenden hier
ungeschnitten
er hatte jetzt auf jeden fall diese
waffen hier das hier habe ich auch mal
noch mal eben kurz auf das habe ich
jetzt hier im sechsten platz
krass dann trinke ich noch mal eben hier
kurz und schutz trank und noch für ein
damit ich mir hier so ein schild auf das
schild tragen keine ahnung wie genau das
heißt und jetzt ok krass ich bin ein
bisschen außerhalb des sturms da haben
wir den nächsten kill freunde die
scheiße ist halt auch das jetzt in drei
sekunden wirklich das auge des sturms
kleiner wird das heißt genau jetzt
nämlich was was will ich meinen platz
als besten sniper jahr in dem motto was
an der stelle würde ich diesen part
fordert jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihr mehr fordert videos
auf einem kanal sehen wollt dann lasst
mal 70.000 likes das ist eine krasse
große zahl ein notebook wie ich immer
sage freunde wenn ihr noch mehr tipps
habt für fortnight sachen die ich
eventuell ein bisschen besser machen
kann
dann schreibt auch in die kommentare ich
glaube ich kann eigentlich so ca alles
verbessern und sonst würde ich jetzt
sagen